la reunión con el presidente Alberto
Fernández La bilaterales a las 10:45
hora local así está previsto antes el
presidente Lula da Silva hará una
ofrenda floral para San Martín el Héroe
de la patria Argentina en la plaza del
mismo nombre alrededor del mediodía hora
Argentina todas estas horas se pueden
modificar según vaya dándose la agenda
Será esa firma de acuerdos bilaterales
tan importantes que están en el centro
de algún modo de este encuentro y que
también se relaciona con la celac y el
mercosur por la integración regional que
se da en este sentido y que se va a
profundizar al reunirse estos dos
presidentes que son muy afines son muy
cercanos se tienen además mucho aprecio
personal a las 15 presentarán juntamente
en la apertura de una reunión de
empresarios de ambos países una reunión
que coordinaron los propios empresarios
pero los presidentes la estarán abriendo
y más tarde por la tarde tarde noche
participarán de eventos culturales
centralmente un concierto dedicado a la
hermandad entre ambos países y como bien
señalaba se prevé Aunque todavía no está
claro En qué horario una reunión también
con la presidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner con quien Lula da Silva también
es muy cercano bien natalio Y cuál es la
expectativa con un Lula que retorna
después de que su antecesor sacó a
Brasil de la celac
bueno es una expectativa enorme
justamente porque por un lado Lula da
Silva es un peso pesado de la política
regional pero más allá de la figura del
presidente Brasil es el país más
importante más grande de la región digo
más importante en términos económicos
poblacionales y geográficos Y eso le da
un peso extra un peso que le estaba
faltando a esta Cumbre este foro
regional Así que veamos por el lado de
la celac es clave pero como decía antes
también por el lado del mercosur y por
el lado de lo que implica para la
política local de Argentina para Alberto
Fernández la presencia de Lula da Silva
es importante porque también le da
fortaleza ese proyecto Y esa esa imagen
de progresismo regional que quiere
proyectar el presidente Alberto
Fernández y como te decía mercosur
también muy importante porque la idea es
que se empiecen a acercar más
fuertemente a Argentina y Brasil en este
proyecto regional Este mercado común
incluso con la idea en algún punto en el
futuro de hablar de una moneda común
algo que se vuelve a hablar cada tanto y
no se termina de concretar O tal vez
algún mecanismo especial para evitar el
uso del dólar los intercambios
bilaterales entre Argentina y Brasil
todos son elementos que vienen a
intentar reforzar el mercosur y dentro
de esta América Latina en la que está el
mercosur también porque no la América
Latina en general en la que está
incluida todas las los países de la cela